there's a new assassin's creed can't
coming hash whew finally it's about
syndicate what's the story guys you guys
had a crazy live stream this morning
yeah we did Isis Creed syndicate today
we named it it's in London it's 1868
which I can remember because it's you
just swap the order 1886 and love two
digits you're done tell us everything
you guys know about what Ubisoft
announced this morning so I actually
went to Canada to see it last week yeah
yeah tetsuo and it's it's very different
they redid stealth so now it's not cover
based you're not sneaking a bushes
you're not blending the crowds you're
just out there doing more modern stealth
you're crouching using darts whistling
distracting people they read it let it
reduce change combat it's now close
quarters focus because you're in London
and you're in gang fight so you want to
get your enemy super up close the punch
of mounted stuff and it's just generally
very different from I think what we've
seen so far in the past couple years I'm
question about the stealth real quick so
is it like you know how an assassin's
creed you hold down the trigger and then
you're in like free run parkour mode
where you just jump over anything that
happens to me in your way and the
stealth is it a similar where you're
like you're in stealth mode and so
you'll Crouch into anything that you
happen to pass like is that a state that
you kind of trigger you still have to
like maneuver yourself into stealthy
positions you can maneuver yourself into
stealth in that and let me know if this
is answering your question instead of
like having a hard snap-on to cover like
you're walking and you're like I walk
into a bush and I'm in stealth and
that's done okay I'll be pressing a
button to crouch down and sneak or stand
up and run away okay so it's less it's
less focused on I'm going into things
and I automatically go into stealth you
put yourself into self yeah he's also
got a sick rope rope launcher so this is
their answer to people are getting
increasingly bored of climbing up
buildings it's very for it was you can
go faster now it's yo just shoot a rope
and you're up there no problem yeah no
it's fair it's very bad man I like it
because like where he was just standing
you can shoot that to anywhere else on
the building in front of you and you can
zipline across or tightrope be wary
o'clock across and it turns all of the
airspace in London into aerial
assassination tear
right so you could sneak in shoot down
kill someone and then turn around throw
your rope launcher up a building and
just zip right out of there which is
pretty cool so in the hands-off demo
that you you had did they give any sort
of inclination is like the scale of
London they said it's like like seven
different boroughs or something it's
seven boroughs it's very big we were
running around sort of this same area
which it took a while to get from one
end where we were to where the gang
fight was that we wanted to end up so it
seems pretty big pretty big they feel
big it felt they running around on
carriages they've gone like Grand Theft
Auto so those carriages make the make
the world feel big I know you saw in the
demo they had them crashing and
careening off each other and like the
cart takes damage and people react like
as you're riding you can see the people
as you're approaching just being like oh
my god like there's something going on
here you can actually fight on top of
them like if you climb on one that's
moving yeah you can stand on top of it
and then jump on to another one and put
someone on it look at that lady it's
awesome the amount of collateral damage
happening here is just frankly
outrageous as we are horses knock over
lamps oh yes I run into them street
lamps are no obstacle that were the head
of a horse well they bred them
differently back then yeah they bred or
shoot the huge battle ones for the
destriers for fighting and then they
built the iron and it looks first urban
I look better for a number of years this
this stuff happens all the time ho
municipal departments devoted to clean
up corpses horse corpses this act let's
get into this perhaps regularity a
little bit are yes let's get into the
granularity a little bit yeah
multiplayer alright no gone nope they
told me they want to focus on a they
being Ubisoft go back told me they want
to focus on the single player experience
and the thing with the systemic vehicles
and the way that they have the AI
reacting and the way that they would
want you to be able to use those
vehicles anytime anywhere having that
having that married to the fidelity of
your online connection they didn't they
didn't have been too hard it would have
been all so weird so they just mixed it
yeah also did any of anyone here on the
couch enjoy sounds scream what's Blair
ever yes you like this oh not I mean are
you kidding like that that was actually
pretty special when it was first
introduced in bro
hood mmm so the competitive play I
actually felt it's very similar if
you've played the ship on steam or
something like that like it actually was
very interesting it was like it has a it
actually had a really big fan base to
people that really really like that and
I and I was one of those people like you
know it was it was slow with steady and
then there were these moments where
everything just exploded and then it was
slow and steady intense and so it was
very different if you wanted like a
bunch of action it really wasn't quite i
agree i thought it was really cool but
it's also like holds up way worse than
even the single-player campaigns due to
yearly iteration like right yeah you
know the same multiplayer mode over and
over again just in a new city is not
gonna feel substantially different
whereas a single player campaign can I
try these new modes and stuff over time
and and i don't know like talking about
yearly multiplayer like I don't know if
call of duty manages to somehow so sure
enough about maybe it's okay with a
sunscreen but I'm actually glad I mean
it wasn't what people went to assassin's
creed 4 so you know focus on it totally
know do your thing and animus stuff they
said yes but they're not talking about
it yet great that's always the way
you're not gonna be randomest untied
assassin's creed name of course there is
there will be some sort of modern E
people they've done some interesting
stuff with ya growing narrative it'll be
there oh I just feel like it's being
weighed down by so much like I feel like
this series is just like part of this
one when I saw the trailer was like oh
Templars in London yeah why does this
have to be about Templars inside why do
we have to keep shooting all this stuff
into every friggin like piece of history
it just ah my question is why do to keep
shoehorning a major assassin's creed
release into every year I don't know I
just it just like all right what's kind
of me sick Roger to come to ubisoft's
defense the studio working on syndicate
is Quebec typically sasses creed
syndicate yeah that's right we can't
just call Assassin's Creed syndicate is
being worked on in Quebec typically the
games are held by the Montreal studio
yes Quebec studio has been working on
this game for almost three years um he
could have come out next year it could
have come out last year it's just sort
of how things fill out I honestly think
giving it to the news
they've been working they worked on
Assassin's Creed's before they did
Brotherhood they did the freedom cry dlc
they did the tyranny of king washington
dlc for assassin's creed 3 yeah i think
that giving it to giving the whole the
direction to a new studio i think we'll
add a little bit of freshness to the
series so when Optimus one of the pieces
of freshness is that there are any two
playable characters yes there are so
explain this this is a sibling situation
we're talking about here twins okay evie
frye born outside of London so when they
come to London you or the player
experience London for the first time
alongside that great evie is the first
playable female assassin in a main game
that isn't a spin-off we had assassins
grade 3 liberation yeah that was great
where we hit yo that was great where we
had Aveline but it came out of Vita and
the Vita at the time was out doing so
hot that's true they did remaster it for
a console and then we have assassins
creed chronicles china which came out
recently which has show John mmm however
she is our first big first big main line
Assassin's Creed playable female I
didn't even realize because they put in
a trailer for is it Jacob Jacob is that
yeah they put in a trailer for him
showing him yeah beating seven shades of
people she they I've been told that
we'll see more of her later this year
she'll be getting her own sort of push
I'm also in syndicate you have a lot of
female enemies like if you're I noticed
if you're running through the streets
and you're you know you're targeting
people or you're on a mission a lot of
the regular Joe is that you encounter
our regular Jane's you have a lot of
women that you have to either you know
kill to get through or turn on each
other or sort of mow down I guess is
bloody Nora can't believe they called
somebody bloody Nora yeah blood turning
cockney rhyming slang into actual people
what is that stand for me bloody Nora
yeah it's just like a like an expert of
to like like all bloody Nora it is guy
damn cuz i thought if i thought nora
would probable I thought it would
actually be he's another one yeah I
think it's a misnomer that actually is
anyone cuz I cuz huggles cocking rami
slamming slang is just like this
actually means something else yeah it
took it there's a couple steps I don't
have a got to that but yeah yeah yeahs
be curious I like it though I give it
let me derail no worries I like that
you're not you're not just it's it's not
you know you as a guy and everyone
you're going against is a guy the thing
about 1868 lunge
Victorian London Industrial Revolution
London is women a lot of women didn't
didn't have didn't have jobs they
couldn't vote they couldn't do much of
anything so a lot of them turn to
organized crime they found their place
in the seedy underbelly of London so you
have these women crime lords with these
hordes of people that are doing their
bidding and then you have the other
women falling in with them so I really
like that they're not shying away from
the whole you know violence against
people in video games of women in video
games a thing but I like that this game
is not shying away from it because it's
true to history and it's true to life
and they've been criticized of shying
away from in the past oh yeah I saw with
unity as well I'm very very glad to see
that yeah any other foot notes on
Assassin's Creed syndicate anything we
didn't talk about today excellent
footnotes uh there are they're already
talking about the historical characters
will see Rob we already have Charles
Dickens great and Charles Darwin or kill
me some Dickens Darwin as well Darwin
yeah Darwin as well and I they said that
there's going to be a lot more because
they're bringing assassins creed two
technically the modern era by bringing
it into the industrial revolution so
we're gonna see a lot of stuff that is
more relevant to us today than we would
find in the Renaissance and more guns
presumably yes we saw we saw in that
scene with the with the siblings uh like
a girl come and inform them she was like
giving them the little info I hope one
of your side activities is recruit gang
of orphans to steal money to help you
and also get secrets to help you I mean
you have Charles stick into in Oliver
I'm talking about yeah get Oliver hey
that's where do you like you get Charles
Dickens to become [ __ ] today like
collect like art becoming like that's a
weird minigame me I would totally route
that it would offend stuff and I put in
this orphan dying management simulation
husbandry it was like there's dick I
mean of Dickens's in the game we're
gonna have little orphans yeah right
yeah and yeah I just thought it was
refreshing to see a child character that
didn't look like some weird short
deformed adult can you kill him so oh I
don't know when are we gonna get his
diable child protect us in those essence
cross first cannibal jewelry
nothing is another stable